anissa corto troisième roman de yann
moix paru chez grasset m'apparaît comme
l'un des plus denses de cette rentrée
même s'il n'est pas exempt d'excès en
exergue
l'auteur a placé cette phrase de
nathalie sarraute qui je crois donne
bien le ton de cette trouble histoire
il peut arriver que des individus isolés
inadaptée solitaire morbidement
accrochés à leur enfance et repliés sur
eux-mêmes cultive un goût plus ou moins
conscient pour une certaine forme
d'échec parviennent en s'abandonnant à
une obsession en apparence inutile
arraché et à mettre au jour une parcelle
de réalité encore inconnue car c'est bel
et bien d'une obsession qu'il s'agit
celle du narrateur pour une jeune
algérienne
mais avant cette rencontre au deuxième
tiers du livre
il nous conte fort plaisamment son
engagement à disneyland
il a choisi d'y être donald lui
l'intellectuel qui a lu proust eagle
brecht et einstein lui le provincial
monté à paris acquis des parisiens en
poste mon premier job
les parisiens c'est prometteur comme il
l'écrit on a le sentiment que yann moix
a voulu tout dire de lui dans ce roman
d'amour et d'explications donald traque
la jeune fille jusque dans son hlm
il s'installe dans un appartement voisin
inéluctablement la violence prévaudra
non seulement elle lui échappe
mais elle ne le remarque même pas yann
moix déploie un style heurté inventif
jaillissant comme la vie comme le sang
dans nos veines
anissa qui ne fut qu'un nom conclut-il